with some ccsd students potentially
returning to school
in 2021 over the next couple of months
there are some questions concerning
whether or not the student population
and children should be getting
the vaccine right now the current
vaccines are for
adults however medical experts weighing
in are now looking
into how the vaccine potentially impacts
children
kate houston breaks down two clinical
trials that are focusing on how
kids would react to the copit vaccine
for weeks pediatric specialists and
organizations have called for children
to be included in the rigorous studies
of the covid19 vaccine
i need to be able to look a parent in
the eye and go i'm comfortable that this
is a safe vaccine
and it's going to be effective and
without studies of children
that's very hard to do in october the
fda gave pfizer permission to enroll
adolescents as young as 12 into its
clinical trial
as of monday nearly 700 adolescents ages
12 through 15
have taken part in that study this month
moderna announced it plans to recruit 3
000 adolescents between the ages of 12
to 17.
i think it's critical that the children
are included
in the vaccine trials so that way we can
test it in a diverse group
of children and monitor their immune
response and make sure that the vaccine
is
safe and effective the trials are
currently in the very early stages so
it's difficult for pediatricians to say
when the vaccine could be approved
when that time comes they'll have more
information on the impacts of the
vaccine
by the time we really have a pediatric
vaccine whether it's actually the same
vaccine in the same dose
or a slightly modified dose we will know
what the side effects and the long-term
effects
middle term effects i guess i would say
of of either the
pfizer-based vaccine and the more
dinner-based vaccines are
kate houston 8 news now